she's a scrap of humanity but to the
doctors here she symbolizes Syria's
plight clinging to life and crying out
for help in a voice that's pathetically
weak
she was born to a mother on the run
who's fled her home ten times already at
just 20 days old Tess liens already
endured unbearable hardship she's
desperately hungry
but her tiny stomach so small she can
barely ingest anything she spent all her
life until now living in a tent
it was so bitterly cold her heart had
all but stopped when she was brought in
and there are so many more suffering the
doctors say about half a dozen babies
come in every day
desperately undernourished or born
prematurely to traumatize mothers and
tesla's mother still has to feed her
nine other siblings the medics and the
hospital itself is under constant threat
from air strikes an alarm goes off once
we're there yellow means there's a jet
overhead red that an attack is imminent
more than 70 hospitals have already been
put out of action this is one of the few
left operating inside Edelen dr. Ikram
is overwhelmed with young patients many
of them critical
but to a very large extent I don't say
anything nothing it was crowded this is
a situation she's a mother of two and
pregnant again and taking us around the
hospital it's clear she's exhausted in
her office she breaks down from sheer
frustration linimo if Tesla survives her
mother water will bring her back to a
tent on these railway sleepers and
she'll fight to stay alive again every
day the cot we're testing nearly froze
to death lies empty her nine other
siblings are bedraggled and dirty many
have no shoes several have bad coughs
and all seem subdued their mother points
out that six of her children have been
born during the war they know no other
life but bombings killings and terror
and that never stops this is an
airstrike on a house belonging to a
pensioner listen to that breathing
there's real terror from first
responders about a follow-up attack it's
a common tactic this is rural data czar
there's nothing else around here and
Russia insists its air strikes are only
backing Syria's legitimate government
somehow the elderly owner walks out
alive it's Syria's most vulnerable who
are most affected the Russians and
Syrian regime argue their troops are
only targeting terrorists and rebel
jihadists strikes like this one they say
our collateral damage still got all
their eating food ready
last night's plates from last night's
dinner and those first on the scene
worry every time about seeing the dead
and injured the aircraft is gone now you
can see this the sense of trepidation
whenever a drone comes up then an
aircraft comes a jet comes and they
think right we're gonna be next
it's terrorizing up the hill a heavily
fortified hospital is also hit a short
time later
the Russian backing is what's giving
Syria's Bashar al-assad the air
superiority he so needs to consolidate
his control here
that's audio we've tracked down from the
cockpit of a Russian jet the time of
those recordings talking about air
maneuvers tie in with the departure of
Russian jets from their base in Latakia
and also matched the time of the air
strikes we witnessed on this hospital
it's only the warning from this rebel
monitoring system that saving any of
these people nothing else this was a
functioning hospital and not so long ago
maybe an hour or so ago before the air
strike started happening everything is
fresh the water still running the fans
are still on there were patients here
the registry shows that there were a
number of patients here children amongst
them and look what's happened we think
multiple strikes all in one go maybe
three four strikes were seen hitting
this hospital which was the main the
main hospital serving tens of thousands
of people in this area and all the
parties involved in this conflict are
given specific GPS locations for all the
medical facilities here attacking
hospitals is an international war crime
no one believing us that if they believe
us they need to act you need to do
something to stop at least at least to
protect their hospitals to protect
critical points protect white omelets
centers they just doing their duty in
saving lives they are just doing their
their duty and helping people why do you
think the world isn't listening why
aren't they doing something because they
want us to be killed they don't want to
hear us they do they want us to be
killed in science from the hillside next
to the hospital we saw jets peppering
the areas around us with air strikes
there was returned fire from amongst
houses there are war crimes on both
sides of this bloody tussle for
territory the fighting is prompting a
mass exodus of those caught in this
ever-shifting battlefield
nearly a million people have taken to
the roads with all they own in less than
three months and they're still fleeing
the bulk of them women and children
about 500,000 are children an entire
city of youngsters homeless and on the
move that's the same size as the
population of Manchester many families
don't really have any clear idea where
they're going to they've moved multiple
times to get away from the fighting
they're running out of places to run to
imagine any man
and in mackaninee a scary mommy
I'm not father this one is very mannered
llama whenever and homina : had it it's
been a crushing military campaign but
the regime attacking on multiple fronts
advancing at lightning speed with Russia
and Turkey backing opposing sides making
a mockery of any truce agreed and
causing an humanitarian crisis on a huge
scale and with Turkey threatening tough
military intervention if the regime
forces don't retreat they don't know
what they're heading into in the center
of Idlib City the desperate are hiding
out in what was once the football
stadium underneath the arena seating
there are now hordes of tents crowded
with families and in one of the basement
areas more than 400 women and children
are crammed together they call it the
widow's bedroom women believed by the
war
now coping with babies who are
fatherless education in Idlib now means
learning how to avoid being blown up by
a festival
[Applause]
a white helmet team treats minor
ailments but there's no consoling little
boys who are now orphaned and left all
alone to face this war convoys of
Turkish armored vehicles are now criss
crossing through Italy the Turks are
flexing their military muscles whilst
politicians scramble to try to stop
all-out war for the civilians trapped in
the middle Wars already here and from
the very young to the very old here at
least they're afraid of Bashar al-assad
little Abdullah maybe just three years
old but he speaks like a war veteran
[Music]
children far too knowledgeable about war
whilst it live burns and there's no end
to the suffering yet in sight